samsung a présenté il ya quelques jours
ses nouveaux smartphones est également
tablette pour l'année 2022 smartphones
et tablettes très haut de gamme on a eu
et s 22 s 22 plus et s 22 il traque du
côté des tablettes on a eu la samsung
galaxy tab est ce lui et suit plus et
elle suit ultra et ça me saoule m'a dit
tiens nommé monsieur greu je sais pas
sûrs du monde dont monsieur vendredi
tient monsieur remonte met au défi de
nous montrer de quelle manière tu vas
travailler en termes de productivité
avec ses produits alors c'est ce que je
vais faire sur d'une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec ea samso
pour vous montrer ma façon de bosser sur
la productivité et vous montre à quoi
ces produits peuvent me sers veiller à
quoi ces produits serbes et comment moi
je me les approprient alors on a deux
produits c'est ici la table est ultra le
modèle le plus haut de gamme avec un
stylet qui est planqué juste là et puis
on a le samsung galaxy s plus trash
alors je vais vous montrer trop qui est
vachement interrogation pourquoi c'est
vachement intéressant tout ça est bien
parce que la productivité on avait vu
qu'avant l'été sur la gamme note là
aujourd'hui elle se déplacer elle arrive
avec le modèle ultra au niveau du
smartphone parce qu'on a un stylet
intégré donc ça c'est vachement cool
autant sur le s 21 ultra on avait un
style et qu'on pouvait utiliser mais
comme l'a cette fois ci il vient
vraiment s'intégrer à l'intérieur on est
vraiment sur une productivité plus plus
plus alors on sera le test très bientôt
de cette tablette que sont super cool
mais avant de se faire le test on va
regarder ce qu'on peut venir faire en
termes de productivité
alors regardez je vous montre déjà wa
vous la retrouvez avec un accessoire ici
je mangerai non il ya des cover qui
borde et compagnie enfin que vous avez
un clavier alors moi je suis sur un pré
modèle donc c'est en qwerty mais vous
vous l'aurez en azerty puis j'ai une
partie derrière qui revient de protéger
ma tablette et qui me permet de ranger
ici mon espagne ça c'est vachement cool
donc je vais avoir hop ici ma tablette
que je peux venir déverrouiller grâce au
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
situé là donc ça c'est plutôt cool donc
la regardait configurer je vais tout
vous montrer ton qu'on a déjà ça comme
ça ensuite j'aime on espère que je peux
venir prendre et alors là derrière c'est
plutôt pratique mais lorsque je faire
une petite pause et je bosse et je pose
mon espen là et il vient également se
recharge est donc un côté vraiment
extrêmement pratique à venir soit le
posez là et lorsque je suis en
déplacement je le mets derrière et ça
protège donc ça c'est déjà très très
cool alors regardez en termes de
productivité déjà la première chose à
faire est qu'il vachement intéressante
c'est que moi lorsque je suis en train
de par exemple de shooter de faire des
photos mais je fais des photos
directement avec mon smartphone et je
veux les transférer directement dans ma
tablette et cette rue qui va
m'intéresser pourquoi parce qu'après je
peux dire faire l'édition sur lightroom
soit pour le poster sur les réseaux
sociaux sont venus travailler une
miniature alors c'est vrai que souvent
les miniatures j'ai fait mon bois de 4
le cash en train d'enregistrer mais si
je veux le faire là ici qu'un truc qui
m'a plu je peux le faire mais je pense
surtout à du contenu pour les réseaux
sociaux le regarde et on va se faire un
truc très simple alors je peux le faire
avec le photo classique et venir
partager mais comme moi ce que je veux
c'est femmes la retouche de mettre en
photo pro parce que je vais pouvoir la
voir en gros donc je viens mettre
regarder juste ici en photo pro dans
photo pro je mets dans mes petits
paramètres qui sont situées juste là et
dans mes paramètres je dois format
d'image et dans ce format d'image mais
qu'au pire au comme ça je les ai
également en rouge et du rosé du jpeg et
ça ça ne va bien on va se faire une
petite photo très rapidement voilà comme
ça j'ai une petite photo ici alors
l'idée on va pas utiliser cette photo
parce que même si je peux faire les
photos c'est sympa ça va pas qu'à plus
jolie je viens dans ma galerie et moi up
dans ma galerie j'ai fait des photos
hier pour vous montrer vraiment voilà on
va prendre cette photo là et là je veux
dire la partager donc je viens la
fonction partage qui coûte cher aux
plaques witcher ou trouve ici
directement envoyé ma tablette hop je
tape et je voudrais réceptionné ici
directement sur ma tablette voilà donc
là j'ai ma photo c'est vachement bien
donc une fois que j'ai mis la photo qui
est là qu est ce que je fais moi je à
l'importer dans lightroom ici up
regardez j'ai ma photo qui se trouve
juste là je la joue tu es là je peux
bien la porter l'âge peut venir à
travailler aucune faute ont apporté je
vais ici et elle se trouve comme je les
prises hier elle se trouve juste là et
là je peux commencer à venir travailler
comme ans à venir toucher je sais pas si
vous vous travaillez sur lightroom mais
c'est vachement bien pour pouvoir venir
effectivement retravaillé alors je vous
montrais très rapidement un process de
travail parce que c'est pas le sujet ici
mais voyez là j'ai le ciel qui est un
peu cramé donc là je vais venir ici hop
là je viens sélectionné mon ciel c'est
vachement mer que ça se fait
automatiquement donc là ça va venir me
sélectionner le ciel et regarder ensuite
je vais dans la lumière et tout ce qui
veux tu optes lumière hop là je vais
venir voyez là je peux je vais vraiment
sûr mais hautes lumières ce que je
voudrais aussi je laisse un peu exprès
peut-être voilà j'ai baissé un peu
l'exposa pas sortir vachement plus de
nuages ça vachement mieux et puis en
plus que je peux vouloir faire ensuite
au niveau de la température de couleur
tu es légèrement le réchauffé et alors
je vous montrais très rapidement parce
que l'idée c'est pas de passer au plat
maintenant on va soustraire la
soustraire le masque 2 et ensuite venir
modifier mon image directement et un
modifié par exemple alors l'expo de ma
photo que je vais trouver voyez ya
presque toujours ni réajustement ciel
sans aucun problème je peux venir casser
un peu les ombres fait de voir ou être
non j'aime bien créer un peu dont ça
vient un peu contrastée et baisser un
peu les noirs je peux venir saturer un
petit peu je trouve un peu pâlotte
saturé légèrement et jouer après sur la
température du corps d'envoyer tu peux
venir est dite et tout ça je peux venir
modifier travailler directement ici
ensuite les exporter les récupérer pour
aller publiées sur les réseaux sociaux
donc là je montre un truc très très
rapidement mais on peut vous dire
ensuite bossé sol à la texture si on
souhaite alors sa demande dit pas c'est
vachement temps donc je vais pas y
passer vachement autant qu'ils ont un
peu cramé ici fin c'est la première
chose qui nous a pas vraiment venir
l'intérêt c'est au niveau de mon procès
c'est la retouche de photos et de vidéos
extrêmement rapidement parce que là je
suis à mon studio j'ai un peu le temps
mais lorsque je veux venir être en
déplacement à lemba la dette et bien je
le fais de la même manière et ça permet
de publier des photos qui vont être
totalement optimisé alors je peux faire
soit ici directement sur ma tablette
soit le faire aussi sur mon smartphone
mais c'est vrai que sur ma tablette j'ai
plus de précision au niveau de mon
hespel g le curseur qui va être envoyée
j'ai un peu plus de courses au niveau de
mon curseur donc c'est un truc vachement
plus pratique et puis j'ai un plus grand
écran pour venir rendre compte de ce
qu'ils veulent ce qui va pas ici s'ils
vont râler cette photo si vous êtes
éditeur de photos vous rendez compte là
beaucoup de choses qui vont pas c'est un
peu cramé j'ai du bruit dans le ciel là
il ya beaucoup de choses à venir faire
et à venir travailler dans cette photo
là mais voilà c'est mon premier process
et ça c'est vachement intéressant et
vous l'avez vu le truc est super bien
c'est le partage je prends une photo je
partage pour ensuite leur envoyer de
l'autre côté en faisant le partage et
enfin il ya un truc qui est vachement
intuitif regarder je peux lorsque son
appareil après je peux venir également
partager ma photo de la même manière je
peux faire un petit côté hop là un petit
coup de chair très rapidement et là il
retrouve hop là voyez mon agent de ultra
j'en vois je vais recevoir de l'autre
côté et la gema photos a été édité
n'importe comment on est d'accord là
dessus mais voyez le partage est
extrêmement simple effet devenir réalité
c'est extrêmement simple donc ça c'est
le premier truc que je trouve vachement
bien alors il ya un autre truc qui est
aussi super bien c'est par exemple
lorsque je suis sur une conférence de
presse sur une présentation et bien je
prends des notes et j'ai besoin de
pouvoir commencer à travailler
extrêmement rapidement ou si j'ai des
idées de vidéos qui m'arrive lorsque je
suis en déplacement et là qu'est ce que
je fais je vais dans mon appli galaxy
note alors c'est avec moi je suis pas un
très gros utilisateurs de style et donc
je vais vachement venir taper à la main
par exemple j'en sais rien moi si j'ai
un brief sur le s 22 ultra up la zone ii
ultra et puis ensuite je veux mettre un
peu des choses le mettre un écran avec
un taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
et je vais mettre que je suis sur du son
à 120 hertz
adaptatif
je vais vous mettre que j'ai un exil
noces de 1200 enfin voila je vous passe
un peu tout le truc j'ai une grosse
batterie de 5000 milliampères heures
j'ai de la recharge rapide 45 watts
s'est pas offert la fiche technique
parce que ça serait relativement invite
avec je vous ai fait une vidéo de
présentation si vous voulez aller à voir
vous pouvez alors j'ai fait une vidéo
avec les premières un retour photos et
vidéos donc là voilà je peux venir
bosser comme ça donc ça il ya un côté
qui est extrêmement pratique et moi je
prends mes notes comme ça et je bosse
dessus sauf que une fois que c'est en
train de tourner la vidéo et bien soit
je prends et j'ai mon smartphone sous
les yeux et je me dis alors attendez
faut que vous en parliez acier ça ou
alors ce que j'aime bien faire et bien
c'est pouvoir l'afficher ici alors de la
même manière jaunards ma note et ma note
je peux venir ensuite regardé je viens
juste là je peux ensuite tac la partager
alors ça me faire un pdf soit un fichier
samsung note regardez up fichiers
samsung note alors je peux me dire je
vais la partager directement non plus
cacher ça c'est le premier point mais un
autre qui est vachement intéressant
regardez ça fonctionne un peu comme par
magie je reviens ici sur ma tablette jeu
déverrouille et je vais dans mon
application hop la note regardez
regardez je la retrouve directement ici
donc ici pas besoin de faire un partage
pas besoin de faire un quiz cher c'est
vachement bien pourquoi pas que ça
fonctionne directement par votre compte
samsung donc ce qu'il faut c'est que
vous ayez un conte de samsung le même
sur les deux appareils et ça va partir
de votre smartphone ça va monter dans le
cloud ça va redescendre sur votre
tablette quasiment sans talent immense
que je vous allez pouvoir commencer à
bosser d'un côté sur le smartphone
récupérer sur la tablette est ensuite
récupérée sur le smartphone donc ça
c'est valable pour toutes les notes que
vous allez prendre alors là tout
regarder qu'on va seul appelé test parce
que c'est un test galaxy s ii ultra donc
la voyez on voit que j'ai ma note je
peux sortir alors que vous avez lu je
vous ai fait des belles notes je vous ai
fait des petits dessins et compagnie tic
tac toe mais je me suis fait là donc ça
je peux le faire comme ça mais si je
veux aussi venir griffonné directement
la main et bien regardez hop là là je
prends mon espen et je peux venir
prendre des notes extrêmement rapidement
par exemple on va se faire la même chose
je m que j'ai dû 120 hertz quand j'écris
extrêmement mal donc adaptatif 2-0 à 120
je propose une batterie de 5000
milliampères heures je manquais de la
recharge 45 watts d'envoyer c'est la
même chose je vois que j'ai un exil 'nos
de 1200 et tout ça c'est pareil ça je
vais l'appeler fiche tech mains nues ce
creed donc là je m'affiche t que j'ai
fait à la main et de la même manière ça
va monter dans le club et ça va
redescendre ici à le regarder sur ce
hors tac et la voyez je les récupère et
donc ça c'est vachement pratique et je
retrouve ce que j'ai fait ici j'ai
exactement de la même manière et après
ce que je peux faire si je veux
continuer à venir bosser ici eh bien
regardez je récupère ensuite je peux
continuer à plat je prends mon stylo
j'ai mon épaisseur et l'a ensuite je
peux continuer à tendre vers des photos
et là je vais vous parler des capteurs
du sang 8 mégapixels je vais vous parler
ensuite fois c'est une catastrophe vous
parler ensuite de l'ultra grand temps je
peux vous parler du double téléobjectif
avec un x 3 et l'autre côté je vais
avoir un x 10 dans les deux cas antique
et hop une fois que j'ai fini et que je
sors de là eh bien regardez je viens
mettre à jour son entrain de bosser et
je retrouve ici mes documents alors j'ai
écrit une fois de plus extrêmement mal
mais tout se partage en temps réel dès
lors vous ayez une connexion dont vous
voyez je peux venir bosser à la fois
depuis mon style est sur mon smartphone
depuis mon style et à sur ma tablette
pour ma prise de notes lorsque je suis
en rendez vous je peux bosser d'un côté
lot si j'ai des idées de vidéos je peux
noter je peux rentrer à la maison
continue à bosser ici en plus ici comme
j'ai mon alors je ne sais pas si c'est
le smart cover qui bordent ils ont des
noms un peu des fois compliqué comme
j'ai en fait mon clavier ici tu peux
l'utiliser comme un ordinateur alors une
fois de plus ce nouveau haut rhin
clavier artiste si vous êtes en france
si vous voulez un qwerty pour
probablement le trouver si vous pré
commandez votre tablette eh bien vous
aurez votre smart cover qui bord qui va
être offert donc moi c'est vachement
bien ça vous fait un petit ordinateur
alors on n'est pas réellement sur un
ordinateur mais si l'on veut aller sur
un quota pour ordinateur on peut le
faire alors effectivement on est sur une
tablette ça fonctionne bien ça me plaît
c'est intéressant il n'y a pas de souci
mais qu'est ce que je peux venir faire
se peut bien passer en mode d'aix et le
mode d'accès quoi ces modes ordi index
d'année ou l'amener ici j'appuie sur
d'aix et là ça m'ouvre une toute
nouvelle interface alors l'idée c'est
d'avoir une expérience qui va se
rapprocher d'une expérience pc on n'est
toujours pas sur un pc mais on est
plusieurs à côté un peu bureautique
alors dans ce côté bureautique je vais
m'y retrouve effectivement mes icônes
j'ai mes applications gras des six
cliquer là je vais venir retrouver
d'autres applications alors là c'est
vraiment pour mieux se dire ok j'ai un
côté pc j'ai une expérience un peu pc
dans laquelle j'aime me retrouver toutes
mes apps sur un côté un peu de
bureautique un peu plus classique ça ça
va être intéressant surtout ce qui va
garder je vais venir vous ouvrir vous
allez voir un petit google docs regardez
par exemple j'ai retrouvé une note
c'était sur le samsung galaxy ace est
folle de deux donc c'est une note qui
date d'il ya un petit moment j'avais
commencé à bosser donc je peux le faire
soit sur mon samsung galaxy note que je
vais pouvoir monter et descendre par le
club et que mon compte samsung soit
venir bosser ici sur google docs c'est
vrai que c'est assez pratique alors
après vous avez les google docs google
shit pour venir travailler on peut faire
la même chose avec microsoft vous allez
avoir ici world vous allez avoir
excellent pour toute la partie de
productivité donc ça c'est vachement
cool et moi qui ai dit et qui travaille
aujourd'hui beaucoup sur excel et bien
grâce à mon compte microsoft pouvoir
tout récupérer to fall a donc à il ya un
côté vachement bien en termes de
productivité ça a vraiment du sens il ya
également tous côtés visioconférence
jourd'hui ça se fait beaucoup un des
consoles alors vous allez soit ici vos
applications vous les ouvrez mais si
vous voulez sortir de ce côté un peu
expérience pc et que vous voulez vous
retrouver sur l'expérience un peu plus
standard qui tablette vous quittez dec
cela vous ressortez et vous allez
revenir directement atteinte à la
voilà je reviens et si vraiment je les
ai classé ici par famille je me suis
fait un petit dossier contre cole qui
est juste là hop là dans lequel je vais
retrouver les applications qui me
serviront lorsque je vais avoir bien
souvent des conférences aux discussions
avec des marques parce que vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que avec le co vite
c'était un peu plus compliqué étaient
tous à distance donc je vais avoir ici
mais canaux de communication principaux
teens um hoebeke c est google mythe qui
sont vachement bien je vais aussi
utiliser beaucoup moins alors hop là
youtube forcément pour venir soit
paramétrer la chaîne avoir mon studio et
voir ce qu'il en est soignée regarder
directement youtube derrière toi qui est
vachement intéressant pour moi comme je
fais de la vidéo et bien c'est fait de
pouvoir monitorer par exemple regardez
là vous voyez je suis en train de m'en
enregistrer les paramètres directement
de mon boitier donc je vois ce que je
fais et enfin que truc qui est vachement
bien c'est d'avoir un petit retour
moniteur alors là par exemple je lui
fasse camion qui est assez peu d'intérêt
mais si je fais un top shot et bien ça
me permet de venir manipuler des
produits en même temps de voir ma caméra
directement à côté moi donc un côté qui
est très sympa je peux utiliser
également cette tablette moi en tant que
moniteur et comme j'ai ici un très grand
écran et bien c'est vachement
confortable pour venir bosser comme ça
ici et ça c'est vachement cool et de la
même manière lorsque je viens faire une
miniature et bien j'ai besoin de voir
aux places que je suis en train de
prendre je peux venir actionnée que le
bouton directement à côté de moi pas
besoin de venir appuyer sur le bouton du
boîtier donc il ya un côté qui est
vachement pratique un peu caméra de
télécommande déportée donc ça aussi
c'est cool et puis comme une grosse
partie de mon taf à moi c'est de
planifier décrire avant même de tourner
et bien j'ai un logiciel qui est
vachement dédié pour ça qui est super
bien qu'ils s'appellent nov non j'en ai
déjà parlé dans une précédente vidéo
c'est ce petit logiciel là et nos jeunes
c'est vachement bien regarder je vous
montre comment ça s'articule chez moi
donc là vous avez mon planning en tout
cas un bout de la ligne je peux pas tout
vous montrer parce qu'au moment où je
trouve cette vidéo il ya encore des
choses que j'ai pas le droit de
divulguer et qui sont sous embargo donc
je fait vachement gaffe et sur nos
chaînes y avoir différentes façon
d'afficher les choses alors regardez là
ici j'ai toute une partie qui concerne
mon planning de youtube donc je peux
venir naviguer je peux vendre mes fiches
par exemple qu'est-ce que j'ai là bas
j'avais les secrets de samsung que j'ai
publié je vais avoir ici les
informations sur ce statut est ce que ma
vidéo et publier passer une idée et
compagnie elle s'assigne aqua et youtube
est ce que c'est instagram cd story 6 et
sa gma date de publication est ce qu'il
ya un embargo ou est ce qu'il n'ya pas
d'embargo est ce que j'ai un sponsor est
ce que j parce qu on sort est ensuite je
me suis créé un petit homme plaide qui
me permet de savoir réellement quel
titre je veux mettre donc là par exemple
j'ai des idées titre des idées pour ma
miniature ce que je vais venir shooté à
quel endroit si elle ça et puis ensuite
je mets tout le contenu de la vidéo qui
est là et dont vous voyez ça permet
d'avoir une liste alors je peux l'avoir
soit comme ça sous forme de calendrier
et ensuite gérard mas to do list
gérardmer sponsors je vais avoir une
toute personnelle au siècle des choses
que j'ai à faire les invités de mon
podcast brèche peut tout gérer et c'est
ça qui est vachement bien que ces
grandes tablettes est bien c'est que
voyez ça fait une très grosse zone
d'affichage pour venir bosser sans
fatiguer les yeux semblent faire mal je
peux également venir travailler ici avec
le s pen aux plages vont créer une
nouvelle et là je peux venir bosser
directement taper comme j'ai mon clavier
qui l'a par exemple je peux marquer idée
de vidéos et je peux me créer voyez là
j'ai une idée ça va être une vidéo
youtube je veux la publier combien je la
publie aujourd'hui on ne veut pas le
faire parce que je veux vraiment merdé
parce que c'est pas du tout un truc que
j'ai envie de créer aux plages bien la
supprimer mais voyez je peux venir faire
les choses comme ça et comme j'ai une
taille de pc et bien je peux venir
utiliser cette tablette de différentes
manières et ça c'est très clairement un
outil que j'utilisais uniquement sur un
ordinateur que je peux venir utiliser
aujourd'hui sur cette tablette où donc
est une vraie convergence et lorsque je
suis en déplacement et ben je vais
retrouver nos jeunes directement sur mon
smartphone de ce qu'on vient modifier
donc il ya un côté que vachement
complémentaires et ça c'est vachement
cool alors moi je vais pas vous faire à
leurs côtés graphiste parce que je suis
pas quelqu'un qui dessinent énormément
mais si vous êtes graphiste au delà de
la prise de notes pourrait venir
dessiner pour me faire tout ce genre de
choses grâce à votre espèce en plus de
ça vous allez avoir des airs jester pour
venir commander à distance donc il ya un
côté aussi qui est extrêmement pratique
sûre de la sélection sur la traduction
pour savoir tiens il ya un truc qui
m'intéresse qu'est ce que ça vient
raconter qu'est ce que ça veut dire
alors la pap la traduction récente de
voir plusieurs langues dont il ya aussi
un truc intéressant comme je fait
vachement de veille et je vais regarder
des sites étrangers et puis si des fois
je ne comprends rien si je tombais sur
un site en hollande et l'autre fois
grâce à la traduction et au stylet et
bien je viens je sélectionne ça ne
traduit directement qui a aussi un côté
très très pratique là dessus de la même
manière un truc intéressant c'est de
regarder ce qui se passe sur les
différents réseaux sociaux alors que moi
je fais de la veille je viens regarder
ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est
effectivement d'avoir cette grande
taille d'écran que sont extrêmement
confort et une fois de plus c'est
vraiment du confort du confort du
confort lorsque j'ai bien bossé je suis
pas toujours sur le smartphone j'ai pas
forcément non plus besoin d'un
ordinateur et je peux venir utiliser ici
ma tablette et sait tous que je vais
vraiment trouvé intéressant alors
regardez je peux l'utiliser comme ça
mais ça s'écrit aussi cool et bien je
peux l'utiliser avec le petit cheval et
que je viens replier comme ça ou alors
je me dis bon maintien est ce que j'ai
pas besoin de mon clavier hop je
l'enlève je le prends juste comme ça je
le pose sur la table ça me fait un petit
cheveu les jeux peuvent venir vraiment
le replier mais quasiment l'allongé dans
ce mode là donc ça c'est aussi vachement
mais non il ya beaucoup de modularité
c'est le truc qui va venir m'intéressait
moi ici avec ce produit je leur pose
comme ça je vais avoir deux petites
caméras à l'arrière mais personnellement
les caméras sur les tablettes jésus
utilise pas sauf si j'ai un qr code à
venir scanner ce que je veux dire
utiliser ici par contre sur les deux
petites caméras que je vais avoir à
l'avant qui sont planqués là que vous
verrez peut-être mieux ici ces caméras
elle me serviront lors ce que j'aimerais
faire une conférence discuter avec des
gens mais au-delà de ça je n'utilise pas
les caméras sur les tablettes donc pour
moi ya pas trop d'usagé là dessus et
puis elle avoue que même faire du
bobsleigh avec moi y'a un côté qui est
vachement pratique et puis après sur un
usage qui est aussi intéressant lorsque
je bosse beaucoup et moment j'ai envie
de m'écouter un peu de musique ah tiens
je me mets sur spotify vous pourrez
faire avec un ordinateur avec n'importe
quoi vous allez avoir de la musique
qu'on aime écouter des podcasts il ya
des tonnes d'émissions qui peuvent être
cool non notamment mon podcast fréquence
grand monsieur greu comme ça vous saurez
tout aussi sûr de la tête qu'on parle de
choses un peu différentes mais c'est
vachement intéressant dont vous voyez on
a un truc est vachement complet moi dans
ma façon de bosser c'est vraiment prise
de notes organisation gestion des
plannings bien évidemment la gestion
mais email le fait de pouvoir faire
venir un communiqué très facilement un
smartphone avec tout ça vachement
vachement bien et en plus ici comme vous
êtes sur le modèle ultra vous avez une
caméra qui est vraiment top vous pouvez
venir bosser poster très rapidement j'ai
une haute fonction qui est vachement
intéressante lorsque je vais utiliser
notamment des réseaux sociaux et
notamment tik tok et que je veux venir
envoyer une vidéo directement en ligne
alors que je peux le faire soit
directement à partir de mon aise 22
ultra et je trouve ça intéressant ok
mais si je veux bien faire à partir d'un
pc c'est plus compliqué parce faut pas
venir et ditema miniature devenir pro un
même et paillettes et miniatures par
contre ici comme je suis sur une
application tablettes je peux venir
édité mais miniature donc on est
vraiment dans l'antre 2 c'est ça qui est
aussi intéressant à le regarder je vous
montre je vais sur tik tok leur tictoc
hop là je me mets dans ce sens là et là
je veux venir par exemple le m'envoyer
une vidéo alors regardez je fais une
vidéo avec mon smartphone que je trouve
intéressante je fais de la même manière
je clique sur partager je fais coûte
cher je l'envoie sur ma tablette et elle
va arriver directement sur ma tablette
c'est vraiment histoire vous montrer
parce que c'est pas une vidéo qui est
fait pour tik tok à la base donc là j'ai
ma vidéo qu'est là ok elle est cool elle
me plait bien donc je reviens dans mon
tik tok qui est ici là je viens choisir
je fais téléverser j'ai ma vidéo qui est
là à mince c'est du 1080p s'est pas
adapté bon ok alors je reviens dans tik
tok je veux le faire avec maintien je
prends cette photo là hop là cette photo
là je la seleccion cette photo-là de la
seleccion ça m'intéresse suivant bon je
vais rien faire de bien intéressant ici
suivant et là je veux venir poster et
donc autant que je peux venir faire
garder je veux dans ma description je
tape ma description à tik tok je vais
juste marquer génial parce que je trouve
ça génial alors que bon c'est pas
particulièrement génial je peux venir
édité ma couverture et me faire une
couverture avec un truc de ouf voilà je
me mets juste de ouf alors je sais que
c'est pas du ouf à ce que je fais mais
je peux venir c'est un truc de ouf et
hop je fais n'importe quoi donc une fois
que je sors de là hop jamais être mon
truc comme ça et alors si je sais ce que
j'ai fait est particulièrement
dégueulasse mais c'est vraiment une
histoire de vous montrer un pull un peu
l'idée alors la voyez j'ai enregistré
mais miniature j'ai fait mon truc que
publier je peux faire directement depuis
ma table sfr depuis mon smartphone mais
avec un grand écran comme ça avant
d'avoir cet appel c'était pas possible
alors j'avais des tablettes un plus
petit également chez samsung mais là
avec un très gros modèles comme ça c'est
quasiment du 15 pouces machault ça
vachement bien c'est vachement cool et
ça me permet vraiment de très très bien
bossé là dessus il ya un autre qui est
vachement intéressant mais ce sera
surtout lorsque je viens faire des
lightswitch et bien je peux venir
monitorer directement ici alors je peux
venir le faire une fois de plus au
travers de mon smartphone mais sur une
tablette c'est quand même relativement
autre chose parce que regarder si je
viens dans mon gestionnaire de stream je
veux avoir quand même quelque chose de
beaucoup plus grand et beaucoup plus
confortable c'est quand même vachement
mieux que ce que j'aurais à travers un
smart phone donc là j'ai ma caméra je
peux aussi avoir un pc sur lequel je
viens tout gérer mais si je veux en plus
d'autres informations j'ai ma tablette à
côté donc voyez elle est multifonction
elle va m'aider mois à venir a planifié
à travers le channel va m'aider à éditer
des photos elle me permet de fin de la
prise de notes à me permet de partager
des photos que j'ai prises avec mon
smartphone les élites et dans lightroom
madfeet professionnel me permet de gérer
au site oui je me permet de gérer mes
réseaux sur un écran de 14 6 pouces
quasiment 15 pouces et une taille d'ordi
si je veux le switch est en mode ordi
avec le mode d'aix je peux le faire j'ai
un clavier j'ai une double caméra à
l'avant pour venir bosser sur la
conférence enfin bref j'ai un outil qui
est extrêmement polyvalent et là tout de
suite je vous parle quoi je vous parle
que de fonctions professionnelles de là
toutes les fonctions familiale on y
regarder des films des séries on est sur
un écran de dinde vachement bien calibré
on a de l'audio qui est vraiment bien
spatialisé on est bref sur une solution
qui est extrêmement intéressante est
extrêmement pertinente et qui si vous le
souhaitez peut vous accompagner à titre
perso à titre pro alors effectivement ça
reste un petit budget mais là je vous
parle de la tablette mais je vous parle
vraiment de rétention de l'écosystème
qui est extrêmement fort comment vous
allez venir faire converger d'un côté un
smartphone avec toute cette gestion
prise de notes de photos travailler sur
votre tablette récupérer de l'autre côté
avec votre compte samsung donc voyez
tout communiquent ensemble et je trouve
ça moi extrêmement intéressant
extrêmement pertinent dans tout ça on
continuera en parler bien évidemment on
parlera de cette tablette on l'a testé
un plus en profondeur là je vous
montrais vraiment l'usagé et comme on
arrive à faire communiquer ces
différents appareils mais on va aller
beaucoup plus loin sur les expériences
plus personnel sur du gaming vous
remonterez de la productivité on se
reparlera également de ce smartphone sur
tout ce qui va être notamment photos et
vidéos de nuit parce que c'est un très
gros focus qui a été fait par samsung et
c'est vachement intéressant on en
reparlera on regardera également la
performance donc abonnez-vous s'est pas
déjà fait cliquez sur le bouton rouge si
les rouches et que vous n'êtes pas
abonné actionner la cloche et même si
vous êtes déjà abonné venez actionner la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié dès
qu une prochaine vidéo y ça c'est
vachement bien là j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura intéressé j'ai vraiment
voulu venir vous parle de ce que je fais
moi de mésusage des logiciels que
j'utilise et de quelle manière je
travaille avec ces deux produits ce que
je trouve super intéressant extrêmement
pertinent à vous de me dire ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous les trouvez ce que vous vous de la
pertinence par rapport à votre activité
que ce soit professionnel ou sont
étudiantes en termes de prise de notes
en termes de dessin terme de graphismes
c'est un produit qui est très cool a une
fois de plus si vous voulez connaître
toute la fiche technique et savoir ce
que cette tablette ne vient vous faire
eh bien il ya une vidéo de présentation
qui également dispo sur ma chaîne voilà
faisant grâce prenez soin de brouilla
très vite des bisous ciao
[Musique]